so what happens when an international
chess master accuses his opponent of
cheating live on stream but then that
opponent turns out to be a retired chess
pro
well you get wild speculation one
account permanently
banned and death threats sent to
everyone
involved who knew chess could be so
brutal
[Music]
all right guys we are well on our way to
2 million subscribers so if you haven't
already scroll down and sub to the
channel and hit that notification bell
so you never miss new content ever again
so levy rosman who is an international
chess master
was also a big part of the chess boom on
twitch and youtube over the past
year welcome everybody to another
pogchamps recap video in this one we are
focusing on one man and one man only
and that man is xqc he's had a crazy run
with chess he was here before the chess
boom even began
he did those first early day
collaborations with hikaru
and he's had a bit of a rough road and
back in early march gotham got caught up
in controversy after he accused a
talented indonesian chess player of
cheating
here's how that went down back on march
2nd gotham was playing a ranked match
against a user by the name of diwa
kippus who lives in indonesia now this
player managed to beat gotham in under
five minutes
and immediately gotham suspected that
this guy was cheating
check this out all right this looks like
a cheater well let's see if we can get
some content here okay
we got a rating chart that is impressive
look at that
this look at this guy on the run
that is 30 days almost a thousand elo
points
okay but how did gotham know kippus was
cheating
well let's take a quick detour to talk
about cheating in chess
because believe it or not this [ __ ]
happens a lot
see there's a lot of different ways to
potentially cheat in chess
you can input your opponent's moves into
a chess ai
have a chess master sitting in a discord
server with you
or just straight up use a bot and
cheating in chess tends to show
suspicious patterns like jumping a
massive amount of elo in a short period
of time
this is something gotham specifically
talked about on stream
the way i i even hypothesized that this
was a cheater in the first place
was the fact that uh the account had
like a one thousand point increase in
about two like two weeks three weeks
uh the guy just lost to somebody who won
at 99.7 so that's another cheater
um and now the time management is just
very obvious
now not long after that kippusches.com
account was completely
banned not long after that someone by
the name of ali akbar posted a lengthy
facebook message
saying that dua kippus was actually da
dang subbar a retired chess professional
and akbar's father most of the post says
subor didn't cheat and that
although he was never able to make the
rank of master because
well life got in the way he did train
under indonesia's first ever
grand master and has beaten other gm's
before
it was this sequence gotham's
accusations
subbar's account getting banned in ali
akbar's facebook post
that set off a complete shitstorm online
people were spamming subor with racist
messages on top of calling him a cheater
while gotham got flooded with his own
hate and even
death threats online the vitriol got so
bad that it spread to gotham's
girlfriend who got inundated with her
own nasty messages
and again death threats so at this point
we've got a gigantic
and confusing he said he said situation
going
on here and when i say gigantic even the
indonesian mainstream media got in on
the coverage
on one side you have gotham chess a
popular chess player and content creator
seemingly
shutting down a cheater which for him
and his audience was par for the course
on the other hand a lot of people were
saying that this was a case of a big
streamer using his influence to shut
down the little guy
and getting his audience to mass report
his account gotham was quick to refute
this sentiment saying that the fact he
called out subor had
nothing to do with his eventual ban then
on march
3rd chess.com tweeted out a short
statement and referred everyone to its
lengthy article on cheating in chess
we would never ever ever ever close an
account based on any number of reports
from gotham chess or any other creator
or their community
all closures are made by the fair play
team after careful review
in accordance with our fair play policy
end quote
now that article i mentioned as someone
who does not pay attention to chess
at all contains some wild [ __ ]
about cheating like the fact that they
get 500 cheating reports a day they've
had
400 000 since august of 2020 which is
apparently when they started keeping
track
on top of that 400 out of the 400
000 were high ranked and out of those 46
were grand masters
i highlight those numbers to say that
cheating happens
at all levels of chess last week i dealt
with
more high profile closures in terms of
cheating things that were happening
um that would that would shock you we
have closed
three north of 2600 gms and many people
below that
over the last week the point is all the
way from my 400 elo ass
barely beating co-workers which must be
a form of cheating
to one of the highest competitive levels
you can reach in chess
people are being accused of cheating a
lot
what's also worth highlighting is the
lengths to which chess.com is willing to
go in order to stop cheating
in the community from using complicated
machine learning algorithms
having that system vetted by a harvard
statistician
to the internal team's slow and
methodical approach to banning people
they're trying to get it right i gotta
be totally honest and give news
i have zero interest in defaming or
destroying the reputation of any title
player or human being on the planet
and our our policies operate in that
we may be at sometimes criticized for
acting too slowly
i'm aware that our company might lose
many pr battles along the way of being
seen as acting too slow
but you will know that when we pull the
trigger not only are we ready to go to
court
but also we're not we're not looking
back despite threats and things that
have come our way
i say all this about chess.com and its
anti-cheating strategies to drive home
the point they
made that gotham had nothing to do with
sabor getting banned
and according to chess.com sabor did
cheat wired cecilia donastasio actually
spoke to chess.com ceo
danny wrench here's what he had to say
to her
quote wrench says duokippus was an
absolute
absolute certain case of cheating over
dozens of games
chess.com determined that duokippis
moves in chess games
matched a chess engine at a rate that is
not
reasonably possible for a human player
end quote
from there ali who you'll remember is
sabur's son
posted a lengthy response to chess.com's
decision
defending his father in it he explains
that his father began obsessively
playing chess online in february
and that he quickly reached 2600 the
highest level you can reach in the
shredder chess app
from there ali showed his father's
notebooks which has records of all his
games
as well as photos of his father at
various chess tournaments
now again we still don't know how sabor
was cheating
although some people were speculating
that he might have been account sharing
in the end though it seems like
gotham sabor and his son were able to
come to terms on this whole situation
with gotham tweeting out that they had
spoken and once sabor and his son
learned about the abuse that gotham and
his girlfriend faced
they released this statement quote
please stop harassing and bullying mr
levy because our problem is already
solved peacefully
levy already apologized to me about what
happened recently not via youtube or
twitter but directly to me
i also want to apologize to mr levy
because of this incident
end quote from there the statement says
that the account was actually banned
because the playing behavior was too
similar to that of a
bot and it also says that sabor has
given up his chess account and has no
plans of returning
quote my father's chess.com account was
indeed being mass reported by levi's
twitch viewers
but the reason of his account closure is
because his playing style is too similar
to a bot
my father already acquiesced his
chess.com account for good and doesn't
really want his account back
end quote what a strange situation
you have a retired chess professional
accused of cheating which causes major
backlash
for everyone involved but then you have
the governing body of this entire
scene come out and say that this old
dude did in fact
cheat all the while everyone around the
world
is wondering what the [ __ ] is going on
so yeah that's
pretty much it for right now sabor is
still banned and gotham chess
is still receiving shitty messages
online there has been talk of a rematch
but
as for now nothing has been confirmed
tried to start a [ __ ] chess
tournament at work recently
am i going to participate in this chess
tournament
probably am i going to win
i'd like to say probably but we that's
not true we all know that's not true
so should be fun though this is my bird
it doesn't have a name um it's feet
broke
but i still like it
so go chess